a rare scene in Brazil's Amazon home to
the world's largest
rainforest families walking kilometers
on dry sand until recently covered by
the suim mo River queuing for food and
water we are suffering the drought has
dried up the river we must walk half an
hour to fetch the food packages and
water the government has sent us and
carry them home on our backs the most
severe drought in 120 years has isolated
entire communities in a region that
depends on its rivers for
transportation 60 cities in the Amazon
are in a state of emergency and more
than 600,000 people are being affected
by the drought scientists say that this
drought has been caused by the natural
phenomenon Al Nino but that climate
change is making things much worse no
doubts that all over the the planet the
climate extremes are becoming more
frequent and also record-breaking
climate extremes all over the planets
this year is the record-breaking heat
wave in the planet meanwhile in the
Amazon Brazilians are waiting for the
rainy season although scientists say
this year it may take longer to come
Monica yanak Al jazer Rio de
Janeiro
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al
jaaz